so some good news for you guys to start
the show first of all I am in a building
this is not a drill I'm in a built you
know I'm serious and I mean business
when I've got a roof and walls around me
so that's exciting
even more exciting we've taken my
Facebook live videos to podcast and you
can get them on the podcast app of your
choice including the new edition on
Amazon Alexa and the Google home device
if you like the show and you use a voice
assistant this will be this would be a
great new feature for you but you have
to activate the show's first so it's
very simple process with Alexa you just
enable the skill like like adding an app
Alexa enable the Matt Walsh show skill
now I don't have any skills so it's not
you're not enabling my skills I don't
have any you're enabling that on Alexa
Alexa enable the Matt Walsh show skill
then you could tell her to play or open
Alexa play the Matt wall show Google
doesn't need to be added by a user but
you have to speak very clearly for her
to understand so just just and I tell my
wife this all the time about me like if
you want me to understand anything you
have to speak slowly and clearly because
I'm very it takes me a long time to
understand things so you just say a
command like okay google talk to the
Matt wall show or okay Google speak to
the Matt Walsh show okay Google I want
to speak to the Matt wall show if you
need to review these directions if you
got life you're like me and it takes you
a while to pick up on things then just
check out the pinned posts on the daily
wire a Twitter and on the daily water
Facebook all right last week the
Washington Post ran a very glowing
article about the child free movement
and then couple days ago the ladies on
the view had one of their normally
intellectually stimulating conversations
about this about this movement and of
course when the term is used i I just
need to I feel like every time we talk
about something similar to this a few
weeks ago and I I opened with the same
disclaimer I'm gonna open with now but
it was to no avail then and I'm sure we
don't no avail now but I just want to
clarify when we talk about the child
free movement or people who consider
themselves child free people who are
advocating for the child free lifestyle
now those are exclusively people who
have chosen that they have made it their
goal to avoid having kids at all costs
at all costs up to an including murder
so these are people have chosen they've
chosen not to have kids because they
feel that children will be a terrible
burden on their comfortable lifestyles
so that's what we're talking about here
we're not talking about people who can't
have kids that's not at all in any sense
what we're discussing now okay
now this kind of attitude
child-free attitude of the last thing in
the world that I ever want is to have a
kid that used to be stigmatized
and now you know when they talk about it
in the media when they're talking about
it on the view they act like it still is
stigmatized to not have kids but it's
not really any more it used to be
stigmatized especially if people who are
as who were just openly selfish and
self-centered and said I don't want kids
because I want to be able to take
vacations and buy a lot of nice stuff
that used to be stigmatized for good
reason
now though the stigma runs very much in
the other direction like yeah you can
have a kid I'm not saying it's
stigmatized to have a kid and it's not
necessarily stigmatized to have two kids
once you get to three you're pushing it
but if you commit the sin of having five
six or more kids then then you're going
to face a society that will just heap
scorn upon you
[Music]
it's true that women without kids may
sometimes be asked about it what are you
gonna have kids maybe that's annoying
but they will not face I'm just telling
you I come from a large family
they will not face anywhere near the
same level of open disgust that people
have for big families so it's different
than people being bemused or just
inquisitive or or whatever about the
fact that you don't have you don't have
kids stiffen them this is discussed
there are a lot of people out there who
are just disgusted by big families
I don't believe me just try sometime
like something from my childhood I had
five five five siblings so the six kids
in the family and anytime we wouldn't we
went out to eat anywhere we were walking
through the restaurant just to sit down
at our table people looked at us like I
mean a few times I was really worried
that someone was gonna pick up a steak
knife and just start stabbing all of us
because the looks of hostility and anger
that people have just seeing a big
family
it's until you've experienced it you
don't really understand it and it is
surely a sign of a shallow and really
suicidal civilization when large healthy
nuclear families are treated with
contempt
and as the American birthrate continues
its decline and younger people
categorically declined to have kids or
they put off having kids until they're
biologically incapable of having kids
without medical intervention as that's
happening it's become clear that the
child-free mentality is not fringe it's
not some little thing off to the side we
don't have to pay attention to it is a
it is becoming rapidly the most accept
acceptable and kind of mainstream
approach to life and for that reason I
think it's worth saying I think maybe
it's worth making a few comments about
it so that's what I'm gonna do
on the child-free so-called movement
first of all the term child free
is monstrous actually
it purposely puts children in the same
category as diseases and parasites
okay a woman will say that she's child
free with the same kind of like
triumphant tone that she might say she's
cancer free and that's intention
now we've taken this term child free
because we consider it to be an
improvement over the old term which was
childless and we don't like that term
anymore because childless insinuates
that a person is missing something if
she has no children but the thing is a
married couple that chooses to reject
chooses to reject the life-giving
potential in their union is missing
something
we use the term childless for a reason
because they are missing by choice one
of the fundamental things that gives
marriage its purpose and its meaning
you but you just think of it this way
you could never speak about any other
group of humans on the planet the way
that we speak about children
children are the only ones who we feel
perfectly entitled to expressly dislike
and even say we don't like them you know
it's not uncommon to hear people say
well I don't like kids or or even I hate
kids there was an article written a
couple years ago I forget in what
publication I want to say salon if it's
not salon I don't mean to you can
understand why I assume that it is I
think it was salon ran an article and
the title was something like I hate your
kids and I'm not sorry something like
that
and it was a woman confessing that she
just hates kids it's somewhat uncommon
to hear people say it like that in
public but if that's not an uncommon
thing to hear just in society someone
who just hates kids hates being around
so it's it's suddenly acceptable to have
a prejudice against an entire group of
people why is that okay
I know people think it's well it's okay
to not like kids
it's actually not okay if because you
know why it's not okay because it
wouldn't be okay to feel that way about
any other group would it
whatever your demographic group is what
if somebody said what if you're a
middle-aged woman and somebody said I
don't like I don't like middle-aged
women I just don't like them don't want
to be around don't like them that's all
how'd that make you feel was that an
okay thing to think now if you think it
you think it but it's not you shouldn't
think it there's something wrong with
you if you think it
again these are the kind of statements
that in the past people would be ashamed
to say they would never say that and
they'd be shamed for saying it and
deservedly so we're not supposed to hate
people for who they are whatever
happened to that
or express our desires to be free from
them I mean what have you said you were
moving to a certain neighborhood because
you want to be free from X group of
people
now if you were to put kids into that X
group then everyone's fine with it but
if you were put any other category of
person into that group that would
generally be frowned upon for good
reason it should be
um
so we that's the way we feel about most
people we say you you can't just hate
whole groups of people but we've made
children an exception to that rule and
that doesn't make any sense if anything
children should be the only non
exceptions to that rule because I can
think of plenty of valid reasons to
dislike most of the adults I have
encountered in my life and I'm sure
people that have encountered me could
say the exact same thing there's plenty
of reasons to not like me there's plenty
of reasons that for me to not like most
of the people that I've encountered that
are adults but kids
you know kids are innocent kids are
energetic they're fun they're
unconditionally loving kids have
unconditional love
what's not to like it if you don't like
that there really there's something
wrong it's not something you you
shouldn't not like that
basically kids have all the qualities
that we have unnaturally infused into
dogs that's that's essentially what's
happening we have kids and dogs have
traded places you know in our culture do
you realize that and now we've taken all
the qualities of children and we've
given them to dogs
and we've taken the qualities of dogs
and given them to children and now we
treat children the way people used to
treat dogs which is a lot of people they
like dogs I want to be around them their
animals get them out of here I don't
want them inside I want to want to
playing with me I don't want them in a
restaurant like their dogs their animals
it's a beast please get it away you know
I don't want to it would be okay to say
I hate dogs and their I don't to be
around them they're gross I don't like
him now you could say that about kids
but you can't say - oh you said aroused
about dogs dogs are saintly they're
Saints dogs are their unconditionally
loving no they're not they don't have
any love they're not capable of it
love is a willful choice dogs don't make
willful choices they don't have a
conscience
you need that have love you need to be a
human to love kids really have that and
anyone who's a parent you've seen this
especially in your younger kids that
they really just love you deeply and and
and and it's it's not just that they
don't see the flaws in you now that's
that's part of the I mean they do kind
of see you as a superhero my kids think
that I can pick up our house my kids
literally think I can pick up our house
above my head and walk down the block
with it that's what they think and they
might think that because I told them I
don't know I don't remember but so they
do kind of see as a superhero but they
also I think they do also see your flaws
and
they'll point them out kind of
innocently they're very honest about it
but they love you in spite of it they
don't it's like they don't the most
non-judgmental thing if a kid ever comes
up to you and just points out something
wrong with you they don't mean any
offense by it they're just they're just
noticing it but they love you anyway
it's no big deal nothing personal
that's why we should all like kids
so second thing so that's the first
thing it's really not okay to be
prejudiced against kids
and one other point on that especially
when you consider what we do to kids in
this society kids are also the only
human talk about talk about prejudice if
you want the real evidence of that
they're the only humans in our society
who you can legally kill and we've
killed 60 million of them
so before you laugh at the idea that
we're prejudiced against kids that we've
got a mass grave filled with 60 million
dead bodies of children so yes we do we
are prejudiced against children in our
culture second thing
there's no freedom in being child free
okay now there are things that my wife
and I have trouble doing now because we
have kids of course it like we can't
leave the house without spending 45
minutes looking for somebody's shoes hey
and that's a whole other thing I don't
want to get off on on that tangent but
that's the shoe thing
I just I'm at the point now as a as a
dad well I just want to give up on shoes
about to tell my kids we're not doing
shoes anymore there's not gonna be any
more shoes in this house no more shoes
I'm gonna have a no-shoe policy and now
because they can't I'm telling you the
moment a kid walks in within ten seconds
of a kid walking getting inside at the
house the shoes will be off and one of
them will be lost just God
anyway um I say all that lovingly though
it's it's um so that's one thing you
know that's a you can't just leave the
house you gotta find the shoes you got
to go through the whole thing but that's
just a fact of life and it might you
know my wife and I we can't just up and
go to a movie anytime we want we can't
go on a date and we can do all those
things but takes planning it takes extra
money you gotta get a babysitter all
that stuff so but that's just a fact of
life that's that's a minor challenge
that's a that's a hurdle to get over
that's not slavery the way people talk
about oh I don't have kids I'm free well
what do you think that you think I'm
enslaved what do you think you think I'm
in jail or something
it can't be considered an encroachment
on my freedom to have kids
unless freedom is defined as the ability
to live however you want without
inconvenience if that's for you if if
freedom is just really boiled down to
freedom from inconvenience then yeah I
guess that's then I guess I am a slave
but that idea of freedom is how you get
a brave new world
or America circa 2018 you could live in
a in a in a totalitarian state and still
have that kind of freedom
as long as the totality and dictator
keeps you basically comfortable then by
that logic you're free
but if we understand freedom as the
ability to live as God intends us to
live with our inherent human dignity
preserved and protected
then our freedom is actually enhanced
when we have kids
because we're doing what we're made to
do we're growing we're changing where we
are becoming something
we're embracing our new identity and
identity with greater responsibilities
yes but also a greater capacity and
potential for love and joy
the thing is
I am free
to do all the things that a person
without kids can do there's there's
nothing there is nothing that a child
free person can do that I can't do I can
do all I can go on a vacation I can go
out to eat I can do I can do everything
they can do there there is no activity
or experience that's open to them and is
completely fundamentally closed off from
me
I could now it might take some extra
effort it might cost a little more money
I might really have to make it a
priority if I want to do it but I can do
it I'm not precluded from
child-free person is actually precluded
from the joys and experiences of
parenthood
so when you're when you're when you want
to be a child free it means that you
could do everything that personal kids
can do you can just do some of it a
little bit easier
whereas when you have kids there's a
whole new life that's opened up to you a
whole new identity opened up to you that
is not opened up to people who decide
not to have kids
so who really is the most free
um third thing about the child free
movement is that it is a it is a
celebration of narcissism
the people who advocate this lifestyle
they're also advocating a philosophy and
it's a really terrible philosophy
because they are advancing the notion
that the key to happiness is is located
within our own egos and so what they're
suggesting is that the happiest person
is the person who is most empowered to
kind of indulge and entertain themselves
person who wants to be child free their
greatest aim is to keep themselves to
themselves
accumulating their goal is just to
accumulate wealth pleasure experiences
surely just for their own sake
for no other reason
I don't think that's the path to
happiness I think that's the quickest
path to despair
think that the people who advocate for
this path know that it brings to despair
because they are in despair themselves
the truth is this joy is found through
work and love and sacrifice it cannot be
found anywhere else nobody has ever
found it anywhere else many people have
theorized philosophically that you could
find it somewhere else
many people have set out on the omission
on the journey the perilous journey to
try to find it somewhere else but none
of them have accomplished the task it's
like the Fountain of Youth or any other
mythical
treasure that people go out seeking this
this this joy this fulfillment true
happiness that can be found in
selfishness that is the ultimate
Fountain of Youth the ultimate mythical
reward that people literally kill
themselves trying to find
and they never will
all they find out all they find out
there in in that wasteland of
materialism and self-indulgence is more
of the despair that drove them there in
the first place so they try to bypass
sacrifice and suffering and work to get
to joy but then they discover in the end
that they bypassed joy at the same time
but what do they I do what do they do
they still come back and tell us that
hey guys I found the joy it's over here
come with me
and they encourage everyone to follow
them out there into the desert
because misery loves company I guess
but we should listen to that
you don't give up your freedom when you
have kids
you may be giving a lot of time you're
giving money and making sacrifices
you're embracing you know a life that's
going to be in many ways harder
but you're not really giving up anything
meaningful and you're gaining so much
more as I said you're gaining yourself
you're gaining an entire new identity
there are only a few moments in our life
when we really become something else
than what we were before there are only
a few moments when we really change
fundamentally to our core one of those
is marriage one of them is Parenthood
and that's the beautiful thing and
that's what we should be talking about
our society and that's what we should be
celebrating especially as we as the
birth rate declines and we kind of just
fall headlong into self-appointed
extinction I think it becomes even more
necessary to have a message like this
all right guys have a great weekend
thanks for watching